[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين فرانس 24 في كل
متابعين نقاش وانا ارحب بشكل خاص بضيوف
البرنامج الذين تشاهدونهم على الشاشه
ويمكنك من تتفاعلون على صفحه البرنامج على
فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
نقاشنا عن هذه القمه السعوديه الصينيه
والصينيه الخليجيه والصينيه العربيه في
الرياض السعوديه حققت ايضا لم تعرف له
مثيرا منذ عشر سنوات ولكننا سنحاول نفهم
ما حجم تناغم الدول العربيه مع الصين توجد
رغبه واضحه لتنويع الشركات ولكن من ساهم
في تسريع توخي هذا النهج هل هي الحرب في
اوكرانيا حرب الطاقه هل هي رغبه في القرب
من سياسه صينيه لا تتحدث ابدا لا عن حقوق
الانسان ولا عن الشؤون الداخليه للدول على
عكس الدول الغربيه التي عاده ما تدافع عن
مفهومها لحقوق الانسان وهو امر لا يروق
لاعاده من الدول العربيه سعيد بان يناقش
هذا الموضوع معي من بيروت جرار ذيب واست
بيفكر السياسي في الجامعه اللبنانيه سعيد
بان يكون معنا من القاهره حامد فارس
مستشار سابق في جامعه الدول العربيه وهو
دائما مستعد للمشاركه معنا ونشكره على ذلك
وسعيد ان يكون دائما معي من حس- حسناء
عبيدي وهو استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جنيف اهلا وسهلا بكم ابدا معك حسني
سؤال في الشكل يعني وكان العربيه السعوديه
تقول للعالم العربي لا اريد ان نلعب دور
الزعامه تعقد قمه عربيه تضيف اليها قمه
خليجيه قبل سنتين تقريبا في مكه تعقد ياتي
بيضا الى السعوديه تضيف اليها دول التعاون
مجلس التعاون الخليجي ياتي الان قمه عربيه
تضيء القمه ثنائيه تضيف اليها تم عربيه
وقمه خليجيه ما معنى هذا يعني جمع ثلاث
امام دائما لا يمكن للسعوديه تكتفي بقمه
واحده مثلا
يعني ضيف هو ضيف استثنائي وبالتالي هو
اصلا لا يعني يمكن ان يرضى فقط بقمه واحده
ولا في نفس الوقت هناك رسائل مبطنه مواجهه
خاصه للاداره الامريكيه والرئيس جوبادل
باعتبار ان سلفه ترامب حاضيه بنفس
الاستقبال لكن اذا لاحظت معي لم يكن ذلك
الاستقبال الذي كان يعني ننتظره الذي الذي
استقبل الرئيس الصيني هو امير منطقه
الرياض
ولم يكن ولي العهد وكنا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عرفت جيدا بانه في النهايه لا
يمكن حتى يطرده كوريا وحتى شكليا ان همم
ان تكون همم يعني مراسيم الاستقبال اكثر
من المراسيم التي الرئيس اما بالنسبه
للقيمه الثلاثاء او النقاط النقاط
الثلاثاء فاعتقد من الواضح ان ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تريد ان تقول في النهايه
بانها ليست فقط يعني هي همم تريد هذه
الشركه الاستراتيجيه وتبحث ذلك لماذا
اشتراك الاستراتيجيه وليس على اقتصاديه
وانما كذلك هي اصبحت الان دوله رائده
وانها يمكن ان تكون قاطره المجموعه
الخليجيه وهذا اصلا محصل يعني المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي ما يسمى به الاخت
الكبرى ولا هناك توجد هناك اي دوله تنافس
المملكه السعوديه والجميع يتبع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بقي العالم العربي فعتقد
من الصعب جدا نقول بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه قاطره المنطقه العربيه هناك يعني
خلافات كبيره لكن الرساله ال- ال- المرسله
للي الصين هو ان ان اعتماده على المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بالاضافه كذلك الى الدول العربيه حامد
فارس يعني هذه القيمه المتعدده هل هذا
يعني انه يوجد تناغم كبير بين الدول
العربيه والصين
طبعا انا بكون سعيد بوجودك مع حضرتك يا
استاذ توفيق ولي الشرف المشاركه معك شكرا
على مستوى القمه العربيه الصينيه او القمم
الثلاث لابد ان نشير بشكل واضح قاطع انه
حدث تاريخيا لانها هي القمه الاولى
العربيه الصينيه
وبتاتي في ظل متغيرات نوعيه بتؤثر بشكل
كبير على مجمل الاوضاع العالميه وايضا لا
نستبعد من هذه الاوضاع المنطقه العربيه
على اعتبار ان ازمه الطاقه وازمه الغذاء
وغيرها من الازمات والحرب الروسيه على
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى متغير اخر وهو اا
انعقاد القمه العربيه الامريكيه في يوليو
الماضي ولم تحقق المرج والمامول من قبل
القوى العربيه او حتى من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه التي سعت الى ان يكون هناك
استداره في موقفها تجاه الدول العربيه
بعدما كانت قد ولد اهتمامها للدول العربيه
وانطلقت الى الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
مع الحرب البارده مع الصين
الخط قطع
القطع الخط
طيب دائما نفس دائما نفس المشكله مع
القاهره الاسود اللي هو هذا المشكل ارديب
انت ما هي قراءتك لجمع كل هذه القمم في
يوم في يومين تقريبا
اولا مساء الخير استاذ الكريم همم انا لا
اوافقك الكريم على الموضوع الاول بان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تلعب دائما
الدور الرائد هي فعلا تريد هذا يعني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حاربت القمه في الجزائر لانها لا تريد ان
يكون هناك بديلا عن من يقود اذا بدك الدول
العربيه لهذا هي تراها اليوم في في اصطفاف
مباشر مع تركيا التي يسعى من خلالها
الرئيس اردوغان لكي يلعب دورا رئيسيه في
هذه المنطقه من هنا انا لا اوافق ضيفك بان
هذه القمه هي القمه همم
للقياده العربيه بالمملكه العربيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكنها كلمه تحاكي انا
برايي تحاكي الامير محمد بن سلمان الامير
محمد بن سلمان شخصيا هو على خلاف شخصي مع
اداره
وبالتحديد مع الديمقراطيين
فيلم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان محمد
بن سلمان يعلم تماما بالامس القريب كان
لاحد قضاه الفيلم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استئناف لما هو متعلق بالصحافه
جمال خاشقجي فاذا هناك اذا بدك تحول في
العلاقه السعوديه من او رسائل سعوديه الى
جانب الاميركي بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه قادره ان تذهب بعيدا في التوجه
شرقا اذا استمرت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالسياسه الضغط على محمد بن
سلمان يعني انا اعتقد بان هذه القمه هي
مخصصه فقط
للامير محمد بن سلمان اكثر ما هي مخصصه
الى غيره والدليل على ذلك انه دائما يختار
ان يتوجه ساركا بوقت اللي هو يدرك جيدا
بان هذا التوجه الشرق هناك اسنان سيطبعها
لاسيما ان ايران قد باشواط هل يا ترى هو
قادر ان يتفق معي ايران في مشروع التوجه
شرقا من هنا سيد الكريم انا لا اتفق مع ضي
فيها ضيفايكا الكريم بان الصين اتت الى
المنطقه كمنكز الصين اتت الى المنطقه
لكي تعدد طريق الحرير الحزام والطريق التي
رسمه
بال 2014 الصين وجدت بان هذه المنطقه
اليوم هي ارضيه خصبه للاستثمار الصيني
لهذا نحن لا نرى بان الصين هي البديل
الاساسي عن الدول الديمقراطيه كالملايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا واوروبا والغرب
يعني بشكل او باخر ولكن هناك همم بالتوجه
السعودي بان ال- ال- الزكاه اذا بدك همم
الى الجانب الامريكي يبدا من خلال هذه
الكاميرا لكي تستوعب الاداره الامريكيه
بانها قد تخسر حنيف او شريك اساسي لها
بسرعه عام 1945 منذ الدفاع اا كوينسي فاذا
هي بخانه الزقزاقات اكثر من ما هي توجهات
شرطان لان التوجه الشرقي الشرقا سيضع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى اتفاق حسني
مع الايران مع ايران تفضل
يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الان هناك النظام الجديد يعني ما زلنا لم
نرى بعد ما هي معالم هذا النظام الجديد
هناك دول من العالم العربي الثالث
[موسيقى]
تريد ان تكون عليك علاقات متوازي ما بين
الشرق والغرب وحتى الاداره الامريكيه
اليوم عندما سئل الى زياره الرئيس السيسي
الى الرياض قالت بان لكل دوله الحق
والمملكه السعوديه الحق في ان تكون دي على
علاقات علاقات مع الدول الاخرى بما فيها
السيد مع ان الولايات المتحده في نهايه
السلوك الصيني والسلوك غير مقبول من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اما قضيه لا
اعتقد ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تريد
ان تكون
الدول العربيه يعني لها وانما النقطه
الاساسيه في طريقه الصين هو انها تعلم
جيدا
استاذ الكريم نحن نحن في لبنان مصالح
اقتصاديه مهمه جدا مع السيد وهذه فرصه
مناسبه جدا للحديث حول هذه المصالح
الاقتصاديه والصين كذلك تريد ان تكون
لديها ما يسمى بالقمه العربيه الصينيه
هناك القمه الافريقيه الصينيه فاعتقد انه
هذا الان الان المنطقه هنالك ان ترى
مصالحها بعيد عن الغوائيه وبعيد جدا كذلك
عن قضايا يمكن ان لا تمس في النهايه
بالمصلحه العليا للدول العربيه
طيب ضيفي من القاهره لان انقطع السوادري
ما هي المشكله القاهره هذا اليوم الثاني
على التوالي تفضل اذن يمكن ان تتفاعل مع
ضيفين لو سمعتها ما قاله او حسنا فيديو ما
قاله ضيف من بيروت
اولا هذه القمه هي رساله للقوه العظمى
الثلاثه
القوه العظمى الثلاث التي تتحارب الان على
نظام عالمي جديد يعني عالم الثلاثيه
القطبيه والصراع الدائر بين الدول الثلاثه
وفي ظن والتقدير
لحل الازمه الليبيه اذا اردنا ان نقول ان
العالم لابد ان يستمر بعالم القطبيه او ال
الوحيده افضل احاديه القطبيه ان تحقق
لنا الاداره الامريكيه حلل لحل الكثير من
القضايا حتى القضيه المركزيه للمنطقه
العربيه
القدس كلها هي عاصمه اسرائيل ينقل السفاره
الامريكيه
نظرك الحل ان تتحد ان يتحد العرب وان
يقفوا على قلب رجل واحد وان يتم النظر الى
نصف القلوب المملوء اما عن نظريه
التشاؤميه وهدم الدوله الوطنيه واللعب على
ما تقوم به الان هو المنطقه العربيه لان
المنطقه العربيه لابد ان تسير بشكل قوي
اتجاه تحقيق مصالحها الاستراتيجيه المصالح
الاستراتيجيه الان هو ان تكون الدول
العربيه منفتحه على الاقطاب الثلاثه تحقق
مصالحها الاستراتيجيه مع روسيا تحقق
مصالحها الاستراتيجيه مع الاداره
الامريكيه وحقق مصالحها الاستراتيجيه مع
الصين على مبدا واحد وهو مبدا رابع رابع
تحقيق المصالح الاستراتيجيه المشتركه لكن
السيد والتابع وهذه السياسه التي تبعتها
الاداره الامريكيه مع فرنسا ومع غيرها ومع
اوروبا بالكامل وهذا يتضح من ان عندما
قامت الاداره الامريكيه ببيع الغاز
الامريكي لفرنسا باربع اضعاف السعر اين
الحليب الحليف عندما الحليف عندما يقف مع
صديقه وحليفه وقفه يعني سياسيه واقتصاديه
قويه في وقت الازمات الاداره الامريكيه لم
تقدم للمنطقه العربيه اي جديد وبالتالي
لابد من انفتاح المنطقه العربيه على
الاقطاب الثلاثه في ظل عالم جديد ومتغير
حتى وان كان يسير ببطء ولكن عالم الثلاثيه
القطبيه طيب حسنا اعدادي حسن عبيدي ردا
على تعليق عرضنا طريق جيرار فكره انه يعول
ولي العهد على الصين للضغط على ايران
لاخماد ما يجري على الحدود مع اليمن لانه
يعول في خطته 20 30 على السياحه وعلى
اشياء اخرى
من المؤكده يعني هو جزء من المقاربه لكن
نحن نعلم جيدا بان روسيا والصين
لا يمكن في النهايه ان تفرط بحليف دوله
مهمه جدا مثل ايران يعني هي تحتاج ايران
في المنطقه وبالتالي اصلا يعني اقوى بكثير
حتى وان كان حجم المعادله حجم التعاملات
ضعيف بسبب العقوبات على ايران لكن العلاقه
يعني قويه جدا ما بين الصين وايران هل
الصين تتنازل بسهوله على ايران لان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تريد ذلك يعني
من الصعب جدا التنبؤ بهذه الاجابه لكن من
مصلحه الصين كما تعرف قوه الصين تكمل في
انها تركت ما يسمى بالتنافسيه السياسيه
والعسكريه جنبا واهتمت فقط بقضيه الاقتصاد
عندما تصل الى مرحله متقدمه وتستطيع ان
تؤمن فعلا درجه النمو الاقتصادي يمكن ربما
ان تذهب الى ابعد من ذلك راينا ما حدث فقط
في الصين من ثلاث ايام
عن كل المقالات المهمه الجلديه في
الولايات المتحده تقول مش نهايه بان
البديل البديل البديل في المنطقه العربيه
او في المنطقه الافريقيه ايران الصين
وروسيا هو بديل المهلل لانه يكفي فقط
لمظاهرات من الطلبه ضد اجراءات المفيد حتى
اصبحت الصين تعود او تفترق نهايه سياسه
قديمه جدا وتتخلى سياسه ليفربول انا لا
اعتقد ان هناك نيه من قبل الدول العربيه
الفائده فعلا ان تتخلى نهائيا على الصين
ولا حتى اعتماد كبير على الصين في ردع
ايران بالعكس
كل الدول
فقط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يمكن ان
تكون يعني حليف للدول الخاصه دول الخليج
اذا اذا كان ايران يعني كان لديها توجه
عدوان المستقبل عندما تصل الى العتبه
العتبه النوويه وراء اين ذلك في العديد
منها المرات النقطه الثانيه نقطه نقطه
مهمه جدا عندما تحدثنا على المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكذلك ولي ولي العهد ولي
العهد يعني لديه سياسه جديده وشاب متحمس
ويريد فعلا ويقول بان هناك هذه الظرفيه
جديده هذه الظرفيه تحت بروز دول مهمه جدا
هذه الدول ليست الدغماتيه يعني قضيه حقوق
الانسان والسياسه والديمقراطيه
غير موجوده في دفتر التحملات لماذا لا
تكون لدينا علاقات جيده وهو اصلا معجب
بهذا الطريقه بهذه المقاربه في الصين في
دول مثل اندونيسيا في دول ماليزيا اي ان
هناك سلطه قويه لكن في نفس الوقت هناك
انفتاح على مثلا على السياحه الى غير ذلك
رقم واحد بين الصين وبين الصين والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه سنه 2000 كان حجما
المعاملات 2 مليار فاصل سبعه الان 2022
وصل الى 87
مليار دولار يعني هذا يعني الشراكه مهمه
جدا يعني الحجم الاتفاقات التي تمت توقيع
عليها اليوم حجم مهول بين هذه الدولتين في
النهايه هذه الدوله المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي هي الدوله الوحيده القادر
على تخصيص هذا الكم الهاء العقود هي في
النهايه تريد ان تقول بانها سياسيا عسكريا
لديها علاقه استراتيجيه مع شركه راديو مع
الولايات المتحده لكن هذا لا يمنع ان
اقتصاديا وسياسيا كذلك تلتفت الى الصين
وان الدول العربيه كذلك مهتمه بهذا
الموضوع لكن بنفس ليس بنفس المستوى كل
دوله حسب مستوى عندما تتحدث عن المنطقه
العربيه صحيح الدول العربيه الان في مرحله
مهتزه يعني هناك زاد سياسيه امنيه هناك
يعني حتى معنى الدول النهار لكن عندنا
نتحدث على الدول العربيه مجازا او منهجيا
تتحدث عن الدول الفاعله التي يمكن ان تكون
بها علاقات مثلنا نتحدث عندما نتحدث على
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى اوروبا احنا تحدث
على قاتله الاتحاد الاوروبي
على فرنسا وعلى البانيا سابقا البريطانيا
لا نتحدث عن الليكسمبورغ على مالته يعني
لا اريد ان اطلب منك من هي مال طفل في
العالم العربي بالنسبه
للعربيه
فهمت من كلام حسن عبيده ان الاقتصاد قفز
على السياسه
طبعا طبعا هلا انا ما اراه بالنسبه الى
الرؤيا بكم السعوديه الصينيه اعتقد بان
الصين كل ما تحتاجه من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هو نفضها يعني
المستورد للنفط طبيعي اول مصادر
اما بالنسبه الى الاخرين يعني هل يا ترى
الصين تنتظر ان تستورد من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او من دول الخليج العربي همم
البروداكس يعني الانتاج السعودي وغيره او
او بالعكس هي ترى هناك همم تفتح امامها
بشكل او باخر للمنتجات الصينيه والانتاج
الصيني وليس لها الصينيه من هنا نحن نتحدث
السيد الكريم عن علاقه غير متكافئه يعني
بوقت الذي بالوقت التي يحرم فيها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من
الازمه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يلتجئ الى الحليفه الغير الغير صحيح يعني
الصيني لديه سياسه فخذ الديون وكلنا نعرف
اندونيسيا بالنسبه لافريقيا ليس بالنسبه
للسعوديه السعوديه لن لن تطلب همم لن تطلب
قروضا من الصين
طبعا حتى حتى بالنسبه الى حتى بالنسبه الى
افريقيا حتى بالنسبه الى الى اي دوله
هي بحاجه الى المال الى الى العمله لهذا
تاتي السين وتدعم وتاتي بكحمام اذا بدك
حمام بوديه بحمل وديع بانها من كذا لهذا
الاقتصاد ولكنها هي تغرق هذا الاقتصاد في
سبيل الاستملاك للمرافق
والموانئ الاساسيه لهذه البلاد لكي تفرض
اعود واكرر هم الصين الاساسي هي خلق طريق
وحسام اساسي يبدا من تاريخ صينيه وصولا
الى موانئ ايطاليا طبيعي طريق الحرير لكي
تستطيع ان تنافس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتستطيع ان نتحدث عندها عن نظام
عالم جديد اما الحديث اليوم عن النظام
عالم الجديد وعن وعن اقطاب موجوده هو حديث
بعيد كل البعد ونحن نرى بان روسيا في حرب
اوكرانيا بايران بالمسيرات والصواريخ
وتطلب من كوريا الشماليه بعض الاسلحه يعني
يعني في مبالغه بهذا الموضوع بهذا انا
اقول بان هل يطرا هذه القمم القمم العربيه
فعلا هي اتت لخدمه الدول العربيه هي فعلا
اتت لمصلحه هذه المنطقه العربيه نحن نري-
نريد منطقه عربيه قويه نريد ان تكون العرب
فعلا مستمعين ويد واحده ولكن ما نشهده في
الداخل العربي من تدخلات غير عربيه
اقليميه اين انتم من هذه التدخلات اين هي
دول الخليج من التطبيه مع العدو
الاسرائيلي هل يا ترى اصبح العدول
الاسرائيلي مقبولا بشكل جدي في هذه الدول
يعني يعني هناك اشكاليات كثيره نطرحها
سيدي الكبير من هنا انا لا اتوقف عند هذه
القمم الا من منظار اين تكمن المصلحه
مصلحه المملكه العربيه السعوديه بغض النظر
عن الدول العربيه الاخرى بغض النظر يعني
يعني
ل ليقل ليقل لنا ضيفايك الكريمين اين
مصلحه مصر من هذه القمه اين هي اين مصلحه
من هذه
التوجيهي
احمد فارس سيجيبك تفضل
يا استاذ توفيق يعني بالنظريه اللي بيقول
عليها الاستاذ الكريم يبقى هنوقف التبادل
التجاري بين الدول
يعني هنوقف اي تبادل تجاري واي معاملات
استثماريه او تجاريه او اقتصاديه ما بيننا
وما بين الدول لما نقول ان الصين حجم
التبادل التجاري ما بينها وما بين الاداره
الامريكيه اكثر من 600 مليار دولار لما
نقول ان الصين حجم التبادل التجاري مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي يصل ل 500 و80 مليار
دولار فانت ما تقولش دلوقتي اليه السعوديه
بتعمل علاقات عشان الصين بتحتاج النفط
السعودي طب ما تحتاج لنفط السعودي وهي
بتدفع ثمنه وبتدفع كل حاجه هل احنا
بنستفيد من علاقتنا مع الصين الصين دوله
هي قلقان هي القوه الاقتصاديه الاولى في
العالم لديها التكنولوجيا قويه جدا ومن
الممكن جدا ان تفيد الدول العربيه لديها
رؤى سياسيه متوافقه بشكل كبير مع الدول
العربيه في ما يخص
القضايا لا تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول العربيه لديها منهج واضح جدا اللي
هي التعامل هل هي ارضيه ولكن هل تستطيع هل
تستطيع الامريكيه ان
حقوق الانسان
الاسرائيلي حقوق الانسان طوخ الانسان
يفرضوا علينا المثليه الجنسيه وبشكل
يتنافى مع قيامنا ودينانا ما لاحظتش ده
وما شفتوش
هم بيفرضوا عليك واقع حتى ولا كان لا
يتناسب مع دينا لحضرتك
اسرائيلي
بتستخدمها القوه الكبرى للتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول ومحاوله فرد ارادتها على
هذه الدول ليس اكثر ما هي الا صلاح
واعلنها
كريم العربيه
يا استاذ ضاني اسالك سؤال سؤال بسيط
الهجرات العربيه الهجرات العربيه الكثيفه
الى اين تهاجر الى اوروبا والغارب ام الى
الصين الى اين تهاجر الهجرات العربيه
دلوقت ولا اوروبا بتتجمد دلوقت هو في احد
بيسافر اوروبا دلوقت
هي اوروبا دلوقت بقى
معدلات التضخم على 10 هو ال 10%
المظاهرات في كل مكان المانيا اللي احنا
كنا بنقول عليها الدوله الاعظم والاكبر
بيحصل فيها محاوله انقلاب يعني ايه تشابه
كبير في المواقف العربيه المشكله ان احنا
قيمتنا كعرب مش مقدرين احنا قيمتنا كعرب
وازاي نحافظ على قيامنا العربيه وازاي
نحافظ على وحدتنا العربيه وازاي نبني على
ما تهدم تهدم من المنطقه العربيه وتهدم من
القمه العربيه الكثير ونحتاج الى اعاده
بناء نحتاج الى اعاده بناء
العربيه
الى الجماعه العربيه
هل هل
تحتاج سوريا الى مصر مش مشكله العرب
اتفقنا على الاقل نتفق احنا اتفقنا على
الاقل نتفق بس عطل ابن خلدون يلا حسني
وايجابيته يعني وهو قريب القاهره الجامعه
العربيه همم اكيد انه ينقل هذه الرساله
يعني رساله اهميه وضروره وحكميه السوق
العربيه المشتركه حتى يكون هناك تكامل
الاقتصادي ما بين الدول العربيه
جدا وباشكرك ان في نظره ايجابيه لازم يبقى
لنا نظره ايجابيه اه صحيح
يعني
والثاني لاقوى في العالم والاقتصاد الصيني
ال- همم لكن انا كذلك استاذ جيرار يعني
هذا العالم في العولمه من الصعب جدا انه
الطالب بان لا تكون هناك معاملات مع الصين
الصين اصبحت هي مصنع العالم يعني بكل
صناعات تاتي من الصين نقطه مهمه لماذا لا
نذهب الى الصين حتى
بالنسبه للصداع الراس في سوريا
سيبني اضيف النقطه دي ان الصراع الان بين
الصين وامريكا على نفط العصر الحديث وهي
الرقائق الالكترونيه
الرقائق الالكترونيه هي نفط العصر الحديث
والصراع بين امريكا
والصين فيما يخص تايوان فيما يخص تايوان
هو على الرقائق الالكترونيه
للاقتصاد الامريكي
طيب
يكمل تفضل تفضل حسني تفضل وصل يا حسني
معلش وساعات السفير معلش لانه على الاقل
هو يعني ينقل يترجم بعض المشاغل والشجون
على العربي للجامعه العربيه اريد ان اقوله
انه همم ما هو منتظر على قد هو قضيه
البريكست بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه نقطه اساسيه هناك او دعوه
لدخول المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصل الى
درجات قياسيه في الناتج القومي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لكن تحالف اقتصادي سيحسب له الحساب
وبالتالي اعتقد ما دام الاجتماعات ستعقل
اسنان المقبله للنظر في ترشح المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا الموضوع في شغل
بالهاتف المتحده وحتى الدول العربيه
والرياض منذعجه جدا من قضيه تسعير النفط
السعودي لان بعض الافكار في الولايات
المتحده واشنطن تقول اذا نجحت قضيه تسعير
النفط السعودي فلماذا كان عفوا النفط
الروسي فلماذا كذلك لا نستخدم دفتر روسي
عفوا لماذا لا نفكر كذلك في تصدير او وفر
هذه كذلك على بعض الدول التي لا توافق
سياست الولايات المتحده وراينا ان كل
مشكله عندما رفضت السعوديه في النهايه ان
تخفض اسعار النفط من منتجات النفط ولذلك
البريكس في الشكل هاجسي الكبير ليس فقط
الدول المصدره لنفط والغاز وانما كذلك
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
نعم ااااه انا اتحدث سيدي الكريم لحتى لا
توضح شوي الصوره نحن فعلا نحتاج الى وحده
عربيه حقيقيه وليس الى قائد يدير الشؤون
العربيه بشكل او باخر نحن نتحدث الى خلق
الارضيه عربيه حقيقيه ترفع القوميه
العربيه بشكل او باخر على المصالح الاخرى
للدول الاقليميه والخارجيه انا لا اقول
باننا لا يجب ان نستثمر مع الصين ولا اقول
بان لا باننا لا يجب ان يكون هناك شركات
حقيقيه مع الصين ولكن ان تصور الصين بانها
هي حمل وديعه اتيها الى هذه المنطقه
لانقاذ المنطقه
هذا هذا هذا هذا
نحن نريد احنا لا نصورها
السيد الكريم علاقه
ما بين الغرب وما بين شرق المنطقه العربيه
هي مفتاح وجسر عبور للدول الشرقيه والدول
الغربيه هذا نحن ظلما نحتاج اليه ولكن كيف
نترجم الوحده العربيه وفي الشان الداخل
العربي هناك تدخلات وتدخلات وتدخلات من
اشقائنا العرب انا اتحدث عن لبنان من يفرض
عزله عربيه على لبنان ولاي سبب من يفرض
عزله على العربيه على لبنان ولاي سبب فرضت
العزله العربيه على لبنان هل يا ترى بسبب
وجود حزب الله حاكم حزب الله اذا بسبب
التدخل ايران حاكم ايران ولكن هذا الشعب
اللبناني الذي الى اليوم لم يستطع انتاج
رئيس للجمهوريه بسبب تدخلات هذا الشعب
اللبناني الذي يسمع تهديد وتهديد وواعيد
من هنا او من هناك من اصدقائه العرب الذي
لم يترك فرصه الا ليفتح يديه الى اشقائه
العرب
الخلجان بالتحديد لماذا هذا العقاب الى
الشعب اللبناني ماذا فعل الشعب اللبناني
كي يعاقبنا نحن نتعلم نقول نفس الشيء
عن ليبيا يمكن ان نقول نفس الشيء عن سوريا
يمكن ان نقول نفس العراق يعني عن اليمن
يمكن ان نقول كثير من الاشاره
انها مش الرئيس الامريكي سيحل قبائل ليبيا
يعني هناك مساحه
للمواطنه العربيه الانظمه العربيه
الاقليميه لحل القضايا ولا يمكن ان ننتظر
كل الحلول ان تاتي من من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
نحن العرب ضد التدخل الشكر في الختام
بيروت لجلال طيبه استاذ الفكر السياسي في
الجامعه اللبنانيه شكرا من القاهره لمحمد
فارس مستشار سابق في جميع الدول العربيه
والاستاد العلاقات الدوليه والشكر من جناب
لحسنا فيديو استاذ في العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جنوب فريق البرنامج